steam decks are now readily available
and like it or not they're slowly
transforming all of us into PC Gamers so
whether you've had one for a while or
you're just getting yours for the
holidays or want it during the game
awards giveaway here are 14 games that
are a real treat to play on it
first up is the Gamespot game of the
year the perfect 10 Elden ring in the
game you play as a lowly tarnished with
the ultimate goal of seeking out the
shards of the Eldon ring and becoming
the Elden Lord on your journey you'll
find hidden dungeons rare loot beautiful
views terrifying creatures and lots of
tough enemies that will test your
strength just try to keep your cool
because a steam deck broken out of
frustration is a bit more expensive to
replace than just a controller another
challenging game with monsters is
vampire survivors a top-down roguelite
Indie Survival game that Charmed its way
onto tons of top 10 lists in 2022 the
premise is simple you choose from a
handful of unique survivors kill
monsters to collect gems that turn into
experience points level up to earn
upgrades and last as long as you
possibly can the game is not a deep
taxing experience that requires hours of
time either instead it's designed for
short play sessions of 30 minutes or so
enough to fit into your lunch break or
perhaps an empty hour in your weekend
schedule this is a huge reason why it's
awesome on the steam deck and I know the
game is free now on IOS and Android but
in my opinion movement feels more
responsive with an analog stick so I'd
say test it out on mobile and then use
that version to just get your fix
whenever your deck isn't around like in
the shower if those first two games
weren't filled with enough swords and
magic for you then check out Cult of the
lamb in this game you play as a lamb
saved from Death by a mysterious entity
called the one who waits in return you
must return to the land of the living
and start a cult in their name and
defeat the Bishops of the old faith and
when you're not slaying Heretics you'll
be gardening decorating cooking getting
married and playing dice all while
listening to a soundtrack filled with
bangers now let's take a break from the
monsters and chat about a talking Mouse
Disney dreamlike Valley is what I'd like
to call a Crossing like game or even a
star do Crossing like in the game you're
tossed into a valley that is home to
tons of iconic Disney and Pixar
characters the only problem is that
there's an evil force called the
forgetting looming over the valley
that's pushed out a lot of characters
and caused all of them to forget their
memory now it's up to you to get to the
bottom of what's going on stop the
forgetting and bring all your friends
back to the valley and that's just the
main story the game is filled with side
quests activities customization and
seasonal events that deliver hours upon
hours of fun it's hard to believe it's
an early access game another cozy title
that shines on the steam deck is Spirit
Fair as the operator of the underworld's
fairy you'll meet characters help
resolve their unfinished business and
then wave goodbye as they Coast into the
everlight all the while there's plenty
of recipes to learn items to craft
plants to harvest and more your list of
Duties and Quest is long so you'll have
plenty to do over the course of many
on-the-go sessions with this game just
know the passengers aboard your public
Transit of choice may catch you drying
your eyes if dialogueless relaxation is
what you're after then allow me to
introduce dwarf romantic this game is
best described as a City Building puzzle
game but it's definitely not your
average city builder in the game you're
given hexagonal tiles each with a
different biome attached you place the
tiles alongside each other to create a
beautiful landscape filled with color
the puzzle element comes in as you
rotate and move tiles around in an
effort to have similar biomes next to
each other in order to complete quests
and earn even more points it's chill
music and simple gameplay make it the
perfect steam deck game to unwind with
okay let's get back to the monsters The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt is my favorite game
of all time and it feels so at home on
the steam deck sorry switcher 3 fans
though the game is now 7 years old it's
still a benchmark in video game
storytelling especially when it comes to
those incredible side quests exploring
the world meeting colorful characters
and slang monster makes any train ride
or picnic so much more interesting
digging that fantasy vibe but you're
looking for something with a little more
survival elements Than The Witcher
valheim might be a good choice for you
chop down a few trees and work on
building your home in the early hours or
party up with friends and take on the
game's most unfriendly beasts many hours
later seeing it on Steam deck can feel
like arriving in a whole new world but
let's pretend you're sick of Earth and I
don't blame you there's an epic space
adventure waiting for you in Lego Star
Wars the Skywalker Saga this massive
collection takes you through all nine
core Star Wars movies including the
final two films in the sequel Trilogy
which up until this release had not been
Lego fired yet with more than 400
playable Star Wars characters you'll
have plenty of ways to spice up any
commute and what's cooler than swinging
swords of light around in space
skateboarding in space but I'm getting a
little ahead of myself here let's just
talk about the base game for the moment
this super stylized and chill
skateboarding game is perfect for short
on the go play sessions each level will
have you so focused on beating your
rival score that you won't even notice
you missed your stop the bright side is
that you get to do another run while you
wait for the next bus another sports
game that's great on Steam deck is
cursed to golf in the game you're struck
by lightning while on the verge of
winning the biggest Tournament of your
professional career sadly you die and
it's game over just kidding golf is
inevitable confined to golf Purgatory a
diabolical underworld controlled by the
mysterious Greenskeeper you must work
your way through an 18-hole course to
prove your worth and come back to life
when you die in this next game you don't
come back to life you just continue
living through your children Rogue
Legacy 2 is a roguelite action game that
has you once again battling through a
castle as a cascading series of Errors
each with their own powers making
incremental progress as you inherit new
trades and buy permanent upgrades the
new 2D 3D hybrid Arts style looks
fantastic on the steam deck screen and
it's the perfect type of easy to pick up
hard to put down experience that thrives
on the handheld and that's it for the
roguelites now let's talk about an open
world Puzzler that foregoes combat of
any kind in favor of a chilled out
coming-of-age story set in a unique
fantasy world full of quests characters
and secrets Sable lets you see its
credits in as little as three hours or
as many as 20 plus the music is done
entirely by Japanese breakfast too
giving the entire game a meditative
quality that is perfect for a long trip
you may not otherwise be looking forward
to some might say that I've left the
best for last and to be honest I
wouldn't argue with those people power
wash simulator is exactly what the name
implies a game about cleaning things
with a power washer The Experience
focuses on building up your own business
and its career mode and completing Dirty
Jobs across town there's no time limit
or nagging sensation to to achieve a
high score it's just you a filthy
building and complete freedom in how you
want to finish the job power wash Sim
was the drug that got me to try tons of
other simulation games like lawn mowing
Sim and I love getting a little cleaning
done everywhere I go with the steam deck
so what are your favorite games to play
on Deck let us know in the comments and
toss your play time for those games in
as well I want to see how dedicated you
are thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you
foreign